こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーでーす
今日は
リクエストです
俺の...お母さんからの...
俺のお母さんの、友達の、息子さんが
まあ、ちょっと、リクエストみたいな感じで
しゃちょー、ちょっと...受験に失敗した人へのメッセージみたいなのをください
みたいなことを言われたので、
今日は、受験失敗してない人とか
これから受験の人とか全く関係ない人も、
ちょっと...まあ...よかったら聞いてくださいって感じでございます
俺の受験失敗談と
恋愛の話です...
あんまり俺、その恋愛のお話とかあんまりしないからね...
まあたまにはこういうのもいいかなって思ってさ...
まず僕ですね、まあ大学受験は...
失敗の...
カテゴリーに...入ります...
受験は失敗しましたね...
でも今から話すのは、完全に
僕がYoutube始める前の頃の話です...
まぁ僕にとってはね、結構恋愛と受験は結構でかい結びつきがあったんです...
僕の高校時代は、まあ、二つのワードで表すと...
バスケと
彼女ですｗｗ
もうこの二つしかなかったです、マジで！
基本的に部活はもう毎日だったんで、バスケずっとしてて
高１の最初に彼女ができたんですよ
まあ後々３年間付き合うことになるんですけども
一人の彼女ができて、基本バスケットガンガンやってって
まあ、彼女と、たまに一緒に帰ったりしてたんですけれども
まあ皆さん知ってのとおり、僕はですね...
バカなんです
いや、天才だよ
天才とバカは紙一重だから一概にバカとは言えないけど
どっちかというと
バカなんです
まあ天才だけどね！
バカ天才というよりは、勉強が出来なかったのかな？
勉強があまり好きなほうじゃなかったんです...
なんで、テストとかもそんな  超ー低いわけじゃないんですけども
全然まあ、５０点とか４０点とかそういう感じをとってて、
で、まあ、僕の彼女は、まあ
基本的に結構勉強が出来たり、提出物を出したり
結構人としてしっかりしてたんですよ...
いや、俺がしっかりしてなかった訳じゃないけどね！
って感じでまぁ、彼女さんは結構...なんだろう
しっかり勉強したり提出物を出しつつ、って感じで
で僕はもう、ﾁ ｬ ﾗ ﾝ ﾎﾟ ﾗ ﾝしてて
もうバスケしかしてねえ！
バスケか彼女！
ｳェｲ☆
みたいな感じで、ずっとこう
ヘラヘラしてて、まあ過ごしてた訳ですよ...
高１の初期の頃に付き合って、ま、バスケと彼女
で、高２も！バスケと彼女！
高３も！！バスケと！彼女！
でもね、バスケはしっかりやってて
そこらへんの弱い高校とかにはもう１００点差つけて勝ったりしてましたね...
こう提出物出さないで成績悪いまま、もうこう、ズラズラと高３の春まできたんですけれども、
まあ、高３といったらもうあれでしょ
引退試合です...
まあベスト１６ぐらいには残れたんですけれども
まあわずかに及ばず引退ということになってしまいました
まあとりあえず部活は一生懸命やってたんでガッツはあったんですけれども
まあここで引退しちゃったんで、高３の春は...まあ...ちょっと彼女だけみたいな感じになっちゃいました
ちょっとだけね！
高２かなぁ...もうちょっと覚えてないんですけど
確か登校中はほぼ毎日一緒で行ってましたね...
全然違う方向から学校に行ってたんですけども
まあそこはもう愛の力で早起きして
なんとか毎日学校に行ってました
ほんとにこの子のためなら何でも出来るって思ってたぐらいだったんすよ、僕はね...
でも僕はそんなね、ｸﾞｲｸﾞｲいけるような奴じゃなかったんで
まあこう、ｼｬｲに、おとなしく一緒に登校したり
一緒に帰ったりしてたって感じです...
まあこの時の僕の彼女のまぁステータスを話しますと
まぁ、まじめです
勉強が出来ます
提出物、完璧に出します、ほぼ
まあ、ボランティアもしてて
まあそれに対して、僕は、まあ...
バスケのみ
勉強はほぼ出来ません
提出物、高２の時は　一　回　も　出しませんでした
不真面目ではなかったんですけども
まああんまりこうしっかりした奴ではなかったんですね...
で、まあ彼女が大切、と
まあいわゆる恋愛に生きる男ってやつっすよ
で、まぁ高３の初期なんですけれども、まあ僕の彼女
勉強も出来て、ボランティアもしてて、提出物も出してる
お前らこれが何を意味するか分かるか？
そう！
推薦です...
日頃しっかりしてる人たちはね..
まぁそれが評価されて
推薦入試というね...
一般受験とは違う面接とかで大学に入ることが出来るんです
まあ拙者の彼女はもう
見るからにこういうパーフェクトな感じだったんで
案の定、推薦を、先生から進められておりました...
焦る僕です...
流石にこれはまずいと
僕は結構負けず嫌いだったんですよ
ちょっと、こう...ちょっと強がりたいところがあったんで
ちょっとこれじゃあ彼女に、負けちまう、と思って
結構彼女が薦められた所は、結構いい所だったんですよ
それも富山県からちょっと離れちゃう...
そこで僕は思ったんすよ！
このままじゃ...
一緒にいれなくなっちまう！
彼女が遠くに行っちまう！
そんなのやだぁ！！！
って、思って、まあちょっと、一生懸命勉強しようかな
と思いましたね...
まあこの時はそんなにこれといってしたいことが無かったんで
とりあえず、なるべく、彼女と近いところに行きたいな、と思って
これも勉強しとくしかねえなって感じで
まあ、高３の部活終わってすぐくらいから
結構本気で勉強を始めましたね...
はい、というわけで、高３の夏の始まりです
まあ僕ほんとにバスケしかしてなかったんで、勉強ほんとにできなかったんですよね
いわゆる、バカってやつです
バカなんでまあバカはバカなりに
本気で気合いれて勉強はじめました
夏休みは一日最低１０時間は確実にしていたと思います
まあ彼女のことを思えばね、余裕ッスよ
一日十時間ぐらい
まあプライドもあったんですけどね...僕の中の...
で、高３の夏からこつこつ勉強頑張って
まあ秋ごろにはね
進研ゼミとかいろんな模試があったんですけども
まあそのなかでも結構
校内１位とか
総合で１位とか
学校の中では！...そこそこの成績を残せました
まあ受験は全国バトルなんでなんとも言えないんですけどね
まあそうなってるうちも僕の頭の中は、ずっと
彼女と過ごせる幸せな大学生活っていうのを
こっそり...思い浮かべてたわけです
なんだろな...誰かのために大学受験するっていうのも変な話なんですけども...
超行きたいみたいな大学はなかったんで...
なんで一番いいのはその彼女の近くで
好きなことができる大学にいければ一番いいな
っていう感じで大学選びをしました
っていうか...絶対行こうとしました...
という感じでまあこつこつこつこつ勉強して
まあ成績もなかなかいい感じでのぼってて
まあ行きたい所には行けるかなって感じだったんですけども
大学入試前ですね
結構ね...推薦入試って合格発表が早くて
ま、僕が入試してるときに、もう...僕の彼女は
推薦で合格をもらってました
これはね...僕の中で焦ったんですよ...結構...
まあ、いい所はちょっと...決まっちゃって
あ、僕の中でちょっと焦りというか...
ああ...やばいやばいやばい、もう決まった決まったみたいな
ちょっといろいろもやもやしてることがあって...
で、まあやべえっと、まじでやべえと
彼女が決まってしまって、俺はもうどうすればいいんだ
このまま勉強して、本当に受かるのか！
どうするはじめ！どうするはじめ！！！
と、なりつつも...
まあ結局一般入試っつうのは勉強するしかないんすよ...
当日いい点数を出したやつが
受かるっていうシンプルなシステムなんです
まあそれでね、もう、ほんとに、秋ごろからは、勉強しかしなくなりましたね...
まあ寝るのと飯食うのぐらいのしか時間とらなかったです
後は全部勉強です
お風呂の中でもずっと、漢文の単語を覚えてました
まあ、だいぶ結構これで、俺も
ガッツがついたんですよ、勉強のせいで
僕が本気で勉強している間は僕の彼女は
まぁ、文句１つ言わず静かに待っててくれたわけですよ。
僕を。
こう、推薦入試って受かっちゃうと
「わーーーー！！！！」って一部で喜んじゃって
ちょっと、嫌な気持ちになる…
…と、思うんですよ。一般の人はね？
ハイ！ということで迎えました
センター試験当日でございまーす。
当日はね…
まぁ、センター試験大失敗っていう訳ですよ
直前にあった点数より１５０点実は下がってて
ちょっと…
彼女の近くの大学は厳しい感じかな？と思ったんです
ま！それでも僕は受けたかったんですよ
その大学
落ちたら落ちたで僕はいいかなっと思って
そこが、僕の行きたい所だったんで
って感じのことをまぁ、親に話しても
親は「いいよ」と
「あんたの好きなところ受けさせてあげる」って感じで
結構前向きだったんですけども、
なぜか、学校に止められましたね
大学は選べたんですよ。
大学は選べたんですけども
僕が行きたいところが結構…まぁ…
…厳しい感じだったんで
ま～学校的には
やっぱちゃんと合格させたかったんでしょうね
そこには受けさせてくれませんでした。
でも、僕、もうその大学しか見えてなかったんで
学校は俺を「ちゃんと合格させたいから」そこには受けさせない
でも、俺のお母さんは「あんたの人生だから好きな所受けなさい」
それで、まぁ…
担任と僕とお母さんで話してたんですけども
絶っ対僕は変えたくなかったんで…
ぼっ僕の………
……
だめだっ…
なつかしぃ……
まあ、学校が俺の人生を決める訳じゃねぇと
まあ　お母さんの言ってることもわかったんですけども
まぁ、学校側としてはこの学校の生徒なんで
僕は、学校の意向に従ってほしいと
ちょと…あんまよく覚えてないんすけど
多分そういう感じだったんですよ
で、まあ　凄い言い合いになったんですけども
結局、志望校には
…受けさせてもらえませんでした
多分でも…受けてても落ちたと思います。あの点数だったら
ま、その時初めて学校で泣きましたね
なんか、人生が他人に止められるって凄い嫌ですよ。
で、まあね
結局僕がほんとに行きたかった大学とは違う大学を受けて
なんとかまあ、合格して、今に至るんですけども
どうですか？今の話聞いて
受験失敗ってこんな感じです
まあ静岡も結局ね、その彼女とはちょっと遠い場所に有って
毎日一緒に迎えに行って、学校行ってて
毎日、逢ってたのがちょっと裏目に出たんですけども…
向こうが…
ちょっと、ムリだと…
「毎日逢えないのはちょっと辛い」ということで
別れました………
大学１年生の最初の頃ですね
流石に泣きましたよ
３年間ですよ！も、結婚とかも考えてましたからね！！
ガチで、一生この人と一緒にいるんだなって感じで
ずっと高校の時一緒にいたんで
ま、２日間くらい泣いて
まじで辛かったです！
あの時は…
本当は行きたい大学にも行けずに
３年間付き合った彼女にフラれ
全て、失った感じでしたね
まぁ、そこでね、まあ僕もいろいろ考えて
あの時の僕も結構、彼女の事を考えて生きてたんですよ
ふつーの幸せな生活を望んでたんですけども
まぁそういうことを、いろいろあってね
いろいろ僕の中で考えて
まぁ一番大事なのは俺じゃねぇか！なと！！！
俺の人生の主人公は俺なんだよ！
俺を第一に考えるようになりました、それからは
なんか、自己中とはちょっと違うんですよね…
自己中とは違うんですけども！
まぁ、自分のことを大事にするようになりましたね
そんなこんなで、まぁ日は変わり
受験は失敗し、大失恋したんですけども
今が　あります！
だいぶ…
だいぶ、方向はずれたけどねｗｗ
だいぶ、方向はずれたんですけども！
まぁ今こうやって元気にね
毎日楽しく…生きてます
まぁ僕が言いたかったのはなんだろなー…
まぁ、受験失敗したからってあんまり落ち込まなくっていいです
死ぬわけじゃないし。
受験だけじゃないね
まぁ、大好きな恋人にフラれたり
良くないことがあっても、
それで死ぬわけじゃありません。
まぁ、死ぬこと以外は軽く考えようってことっすよ！要するに！
ていう、僕の勝手な結論にたどり着い…きました…
どうですか
受験失敗した人
励まされましたか？
ハイッ！
されてないですね☆
ま、こんな感じの高校時代を送ってたわけです。
というわけで！！
今から受験する人、本気で勉強してみてください
「意味ない」と思っちゃうかもしんないけど
「意味ないこと」にしっかり頑張れる奴って多分強いですから
「意味ない事」すら頑張れない奴は
「意味あること」も頑張れません…たぶん…
どっかで止まります
まぁ、そういう勉強とかそういうちょっと
楽しくない事もしっかり頑張れる奴が
まぁ、人生でも頑張れるんじゃないかなと思います。僕は！
キマっただろぅ！！☆
マミーどう！？今のでいいデスカ！！
ハイっありがとうございます！
是非　みんなも自分…大切にしましょう
そんでっ好きなこと、してください
じゃぁな！！